it's a dramatic Fall From Grace for a
man who was once Mexico's top cop in the
drug war enero Garcia Luna found guilty
of corruption by a jury at the federal
court in Brooklyn guilty also of helping
the notorious Sinaloa drug cartel beat
its Rivals and smuggle cocaine into the
United States the trial heard some
Sensational testimony like from Oscar
Nava Valencia known as El Lobo of the
millennial cartel he testified he paid
Garcia Luna three million dollars in
protection money at a car wash in
Guadalajara
then there was Sergio Villarreal known
as El Grande from the Beltran Leyva
cartel
he claimed in the early 2000s Garcia
Luna regularly received payments of more
than a million dollars each stuffed into
bags at a safe house in Mexico City the
jury also heard testimony that Garcia
Luna even helped cartel leader Arturo
Beltran Leyva escaped from a raid in
Acapulco in 2008. Garcia Luna's defense
team pointed out that no hard evidence
of his corruption was presented and that
the prosecution's case was made up of
the word of quote a bunch of killers
kidnappers torturers and fraudsters But
ultimately it was enough for the jury
Garcia Luna is the highest ranking
Mexican government official to ever face
trial in the United States the fact he
was brought to Justice here is now
raising questions South of the Border
when we are looking at this trial we're
also
reminding ourselves of all the work that
our own Mexican prosecutors have not
done
after the verdict was delivered Garcia
Luna's wife seen here in the gray hat
refused to answer reporters questions as
she left the court into a waiting car
her husband now faces at least a decade
in prison when he is sentenced later for
crimes it will serve as a damning
indictment of the war on drug cartels
but may do little to stem the flow of
drugs into the United States
Gabriel ozando Al Jazeera New York